what is happening are we waiting for
this truck to unload produce did before
[ __ ]
I'm begging you're not hey don't talk to
my husband like that you come over here
you say that to my soul come over here
right [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you oh
honey I got I got him what's going on
with you think I'm just anxious you know
everybody walk with our friends
last week we will adults will removed
here turn 19 again it's a Brazilian the
friend group is bad I know you love your
college friends but every time you get
together with them you'll become a bunch
of little [ __ ]
you never know loud we got like 20 years
of a good sis build-up it all just get
so competitive we don't have to grunt
every time you hit the ball I don't even
hear myself
I'm just so kind of really it sounds
like you're taking a [ __ ] I've been here
ten minutes you've taken 3,000 shits now
that's how it sounds like when I poop
I love my life I just wonder what would
happen if it was blown to smithereens
and I got to start all over again
so it has nothing to do with your affair
[Music]
it's a stupid college hook it never
ended it's just calling it an affair
because you guys are married to other
people and having sex with each other
it's job there evil [ __ ] how do you
sleep with women that are half your age
it's soul-crushing
we're good people this part is mommy
fault sir we're such bad people
[Music]
do you want to have a child I don't know
the type of person has to have meaning
in their life
[Music]
it's just things that matter in this
world nipples and butts and he's got all
three
[Music]
I want everyone to know that after a
long talk with max last night I have
decided to go ahead and try to like you
- evil
what are you guys doing - slow-motion
slow-mo it's really cool your swimmer
yeah and like laying slow
[Music]